Ai In 2019 hot dog,
not hot dog at the same time hello world,
it's Saroj and 2019 is going to be an
incredible year for the Ai Community.
I'm going to briefly recap some of the
major highlights in the field from 2018
then use some of those highlights to
make 10 predictions on what's going to
happen in 2019 the subset of AI deep
learning has accounted for the majority of
the public discourse on Ai in 2018 we've
seen some incredible new applications
of it so far, but let me start by
stating something that might shock you.
Even though I'm ethnically Indian,
my mom was born in Kenya,
which technically makes me an
African American, but besides that,
a substantial fraction of the biggest
developments in deep learning.
We're more akin to tuning
existing techniques versus
creating qualitatively new
ideas.
It's been a year of refining existing
algorithms and the ones that received the
most press combined deep learning
and reinforcement learning together.
This technique,
deep reinforcement learning enabled
open AI's Bot to defeat the world's best
dota players.
It enabled deep mind spot to beat the
world's best go player and enables Uber's
bots to beat Montezuma's revenge.
The idea is that made up these algorithms
were all at least a decade old.
They just been combined in novel
ways to defeat these games.
The idea is that if an AI can learn how
to optimize its score in a game world,
it could possibly also learn how to
optimize any function in the real world,
which deep minds Alpha fold actually
did later in the year by predicting the
three d shapes of proteins,
enabling scientists to design new cures
for diseases much more efficiently in
terms of global developer activity.
The two hottest areas of AI on good
hub centered around NLP and generative
modeling.
It was a successful application
of transfer learning
applied to NLP that brought
such incredible results.
Transfer learning is the art of being
able to apply pretrained models to data.
The pretrained image net model help
accelerate the development of computer
vision algorithms a few years ago and
in 2018 fast that AI's Ulm fit the Allen
Institute Elmo open AI's transformer
and Google's Bert did the same thing for
NLP. These pretrained models
help accelerate development.
Google's Bert stands for by Directional
encoder representation from transformers
come down, optimist, not you.
It was a model that was built on the
ideas of the other pretrained models and
redefine the state of the art
for 11 different NLP tasks,
even surpassing human performance.
And the challenging area of question
answering it made learning from text data
far easier for any developer since it
meant instead of lengthy training times
only minimal changes needed to
be made to the existing model,
which made training processes
more like fine tuning.
The other area with lots of
activity was generative models,
models that create novel
data like video or text,
specifically around generative
adversarial networks.
So many variations of gans were released,
big gans,
aggressively growing gans and video even
used again to generate an entire three
d world, which they demoed at
the most popular Ai Conference
of the year. No rips.
Their paper was titled
Video to Video Synthesis.
We also saw a massive growth in the size
of the Ai community across all metrics.
In 2018 number of students
enrolled in AI at universities,
new online offerings like school of Ai,
developer activity on get hub,
conference attendance,
number of AI businesses.
Ai means global interest in
this technology increased
massively and although
tensorflow flow is still the most
popular machine learning library overall,
academia started to prefer
the Pie Torch Library. Lastly,
in 2018 we saw much more of an
intersection between governments and AI.
Palentier helped city governments
implement predictive policing.
Technology defined the likelihood that
certain individuals would commit a crime
in the future.
Tesla's autopilot crash caused lawmakers
to consider the implications of self
driving cars more deeply. Google
employees protested against project Maven,
which was aimed at using AI to help the
u s military improve its efficiency.
Cambridge Analytica came under fire
after it was reported that Facebook gave
them access to the private data
of more than 50 million users,
which they used for political purposes.
Zuckerberg had to testify in front of
Congress which showed how embarrassingly
inept lawmakers were at understanding
this technology that EU enacted Gdpr,
which required businesses to protect
the personal data and privacy of EU
citizens. Many other countries
followed and China supercharged.
It's economic growth by applying AI to,
well everything.
2018 was quite a wild ride and I'm
expecting 2019 to be an even wilder one.
My first prediction is that client side
training will become a linchpin of AI
model learning within edge mobile and
robotic process automation applications.
Several Ios apps have already started
using the device side AI training,
ensuring that face id recognizes users
consistently at people's pictures or
accurately grouped in the photos app
and that the keyboard can predict what
you'll type.
We'll see the pendulum in AI shift from
a focus on the cloud to the edge cost.
Drivers for this trend
are firstly bandwidth,
meaning semi connected environments and
expensive cellular considerations as
well as storage, which reduces the
amount of data sent to the cloud.
This means that the dominant
AI development frameworks
will be re-engineered for
superior cloud to edge
performance optimizing its
runtime for whatever platform
it's running on Intel's
popular deep learning USB
stick demonstrated one step in
this and whether at the cloud or at
the edge Coobernetti's orchestrated
containers will become an
integral part of the AI pipeline.
Coobernetti's is an open source
project for automating deployment,
scaling and management of
containerized applications.
Containers gained traction in AI because
there are a lot more space efficient
than virtual machines.
In 2018 lots of AI tool vendors
started supporting the deployment of
containerized statistical models inside
of cloud native computing environments.
In 2019 even more,
we'll support deployment of containerized
AI models for orchestration across
Kubernetes clusters and increasingly
heterogeneous pipelines.
Cuba flow by Google is one project that
does this well and it will be a likely
target that tool vendors will implement
and as AI gets deployed everywhere,
upskilling non AI professionals to work
with AI will become an even more crucial
part of any workforce strategy.
Literally keep calm and learn AI.
Thus a new class of tools like auto ml,
which streamlines and automates part of
the process for creating AI models will
democratize AI even
further for these people.
In 2019 auto ml will improve such
that any supervised learning task,
meaning one where a label is involved,
we'll be able to have algorithmic
selection and hyper parameter optimization
confidently automated by a computer.
It won't be a replacement
for the ML toolbox. Just
another tool to include in it.
Supervised learning is currently
the dominant approach and AI,
but it often requires the labor intensive
and time consuming process of getting
humans to manually annotate data.
There are also limits on what it can do.
We need a better way to bridge
the gap between representation,
learning and causal reasoning.
In 2019 research attention will turn
away from supervised learning and towards
unsupervised and reinforcement learning.
For example,
a recent paper titled Unsupervised
Neural Machine Translation showed that
unsupervised learning can help
solve language translation.
The problem with supervised translation
is that you need parallel sentences to
show an algorithm to directly not words
from a source text and say English into
a target.
Texts like Hindi.
The paper showed that by training a joint
embedding space between an Incode or
model and a decoder model,
a weak form of unsupervised
translation could be learned.
This was an inspiring step in the right
direction and we'll see more of that
this year.
We'll also see more of a popularization
of reinforcement learning techniques
until coach ray RL Google.
Dopamine will start to see more of these
are l libraries being incorporated into
enterprise environments.
We'll see more on the use of imitation
learning where agents learn directly from
the human supervisor and we'll also see
evolutionary strategies in use to solve
challenges faced in our l expect much
more data efficient RL algorithms.
Since all of us don't have hundreds of
GPS like deep mind does except for this
guy training alpha go on,
a single GPU will likely become a
reality in 2018 the deep fakes algorithm
awakened the public to just how
powerful generative models could be.
Even the Hollywood reporter reached out
to interview me about the potentials
last year.
This technology will mature in 2019
and we'll likely see the first major
political scandal that uses it occur.
We'll also see a company use a generative
model to automatically create digital
walkthroughs for how Spiers museum
tours or even generate content for video
games. Basically, the tools
for generative modeling,
we'll continue to improve and all of these
incredible learning algorithms can be
sped up by certain types of hardware.
Quantum processors are one
great candidate for this.
D-Wave released it's quantum API.
Ibm and Righetti invited more developers
to use their quantum API and we'll
start seeing at least a few examples of
enterprise applications using quantum
computing to speed up their
machine learning algorithms.
There's a lot of promise around using
quantum chips to speed up training time
for certain ml algorithms like variational
auto encoders and quantum won't be
the only hardware we'll see progress on.
All sorts of AI systems on chips will
dominate the hardware accelerator wares.
In 2019 we'll see a steady stream of
fresh hardware innovations in gps,
tensor core processing units, field
programmable gate arrays, and so on.
They'll come to market and
support faster and more efficient.
Ai Processing and companies
will increasingly uses
technology for social good
after the dark cloud that
Cambridge Analytica casts
on the community last year,
society is demanding that companies
have a higher social purpose.
In 2019 we will see an
increase in initiatives like
Google's Ai for social good
program and Microsoft's Ai
for good initiative companies
will have to adapt not
just morally but their
business models as well.
They'll either become more data driven
in their decision making or not and be
disrupted by those that do.
Lastly,
Ai will create more jobs than
it takes according to gardener.
At 1.8 million jobs will
be lost to automation with
manufacturing in particular
singled out, but 2.3 million will
be created primarily in education,
healthcare,
and the public sector.
That totally makes sense as
the vast troves of health data,
the need for personalized education
and various societal problems,
all points in this direction.
There is so much to be excited for
in 2019 three things to remember.
Ai In 2018 was characterized by fine
tuning architectures in deep reinforcement
learning, natural language
processing and generative modeling.
Ai In 2019 will be characterized
by more client side training tools,
advances in unsupervised learning,
reinforcement learning,
and much better AI hardware.
Oh,
and prepare for more data regulations
to be enacted across the globe.
We're all waking up to the
power and potential of data.
I and the rest of the school of
AI wish you a very happy new year.
Wizards 2019 will be our time to shine.
What's one goal you have this year?
Share it with me in the comment
section and please subscribe for more
programming videos for now. I've got
a course plan, so thanks for watching.